feliks yen playing to a crowd of half a
million people at the recent party to
celebrate the 25th anniversary of German
reunification in Berlin it's been a
meteoric rise for the young DJ over the
last year dababneh ma I always dreamed
of becoming a famous DJ I also knew that
meant creating original tracks and not
just putting on records that's why I
started going deeper with the material
Janne first came to attention with his
house remix of Cheerleader which topped
the charts in the u.s. the UK Germany
and elsewhere
the original 2012 track was a relatively
unknown reggae pop song by Jamaican
artist Amy some people imagine a huge
studio with thousands of code producers
but it was just me on my computer I even
did the mixing myself using a track
pattern faders then it went to the
record label for mastering it was an
honour to be able to do the remix but we
weren't expecting it to be a
breakthrough hit Levias mechanics of
atlantis inaudible hatever he followed
up on that success with a cover of Chaka
Khan's 80s classic ain't no body in
April 2015
his second global chart topper was again
more or less produced in his bedroom 2
litres of course each track has also got
co-producers but it happens organically
you go into the studio meet a singer
have an idea together and someone else
walks in and turns a few knobs every
successful pop single has at least three
four people involved in it posting as an
innocence that I feel lighter metallic
Felix yen's dance friendly sound is in
big demand
just like fellow German DJ Robin Schulz
who he knows from his globe-trotting
travels
well I meant roughly a year and a half
ago I bump into him everywhere just last
week I was in LA he also happened to be
there for a different gig in Vegas the
festival festival circuit and working in
the same genre means our paths cross
pretty often
gigs and hits across the planet at the
moment things seem to be working out for
the 21 year old DJ but does rising fame
mean rising pressure don't worry about
being a one-hit wonder I might not have
another hit in America but it would be
amazing especially if the song were
completely my own I'm just going to
carry on what I'm doing for now at least
Felix Yan seems to be on the right track